good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy hump day we
made it to the middle of the week
congratulations pat yourselves on the
back you did it you deserve it woohoo
happy hump day everyone what an exciting
day we're
cruising down the hill of the week we
are getting over the hump and that's
really exciting
it's really exciting and you know what i
didn't even realize it was home today
that's why i love my job let me tell you
why because
at 10 30 every morning i know what day
it is you know i didn't even think about
what day it was at all while i was
getting dressed only when i
when the words came out of my mouth did
i realize it was wednesday and now i've
just been given like a burst of joy yeah
i realized it was wednesday but i never
realized it's hump day until we're
sitting here
talking about how we're gonna hum
someone we love today until i come into
the studio and wrap my legs around you
i'm looking for you
so yes by the way we only have three
more shows left in the year 2021
including this one speaking of 2021 we
actually recorded such a fun podcast
episode yesterday
reviewing and recapping all of our
favorite things of the year tv shows
books songs stories music etc and it was
a great way to
round up the year and move forward into
the next one yeah i feel like i kind of
unburdened myself in the podcast episode
like this is what i liked i'm ready for
new things and it's important to just
like take stock of your year where
you're at of course like you need to you
know look in the rear view in order to
see where you're going
and i feel as though that's what we did
you know i feel as though that is i love
year-end reviews i honestly i wish there
were more like in the stories and stuff
there haven't been like a ton of like
best dogs
recaps and i always just love them me
too what would you say was besides like
for what we enjoyed like what was the tv
show of the year because last year it
was like so queen's gambit
what do you feel like the biggest show
of the year like so it would have to be
something something that was like a one
season yeah like the first season of
something like i feel like it might be
like
white lotus oh my god yeah i forgot
about white lotus white lotus i don't
want to spoil anything but it didn't
make my top five best tv shows list only
because while it was like probably one
of the biggest shows of the year i
didn't find myself enjoying it like the
show was so [ __ ] slow but that was i
think the show everyone kind of like
gathered around and like became obsessed
with briefly yes i completely forgot
about white lotus i wonder if i would
have remembered if it would have been on
my tops probably not because i didn't
like it until the end of course and then
like just like a man take a dump
everything that was so funny even though
it was so uncalled for and unnecessary
it was genuinely it was original and
like i don't find duty funny no you
don't but they made it really funny no
like you read you know franny and zoe
you don't find duty funny no i don't
find duty funny but it was a funny duty
i'm not gonna lie like i have you know i
have found duty funny you you it's okay
i don't say i wouldn't say i frequently
find judy funny but i'm not gonna lie to
my audience and say i've never found
duty funny you know two types of people
in this world people who find duty funny
and people who don't and i'm sorry like
sometimes duty is funny like
that's the name of today's episode 100
is duty funny question mark
um we've got a great show for you guys
today fast five we got a little tv recap
vanderpump rules was on last night and
my blood was boiling my blood was truly
boiling over my blood was boiling but
you know what i did this morning i
finally took our advice from a few weeks
ago of listening to a podcast while we
got while i got ready because there's
been one episode i've been dying to
listen to and that's give them lala with
sophia with an f oh i thought you were
gonna say the one where she like talks
about no no i feel like so she there's
been a few where people like she's
talking about it listen here right and
it's still been pretty vague and i
actually felt like in her interview with
sophia she talked about it more than she
does when she's like sitting down to
talk about it did you
i need to let everyone know lala and
randall are not getting back together no
of course like not even close do you
know that lala filmed the reunion
remotely while everyone else was there
and katie did too because he got sick
that morning i saw on her instagram i
didn't say whether or not it was kobe
but i guess if like you're running a
fever and not feeling well like don't go
into the yeah of course and that's just
a good lesson that everybody should
learn beyond kobe like i think yeah like
the fact that people were like just
going in sick
before well the fact that you get like a
certain number of sick days like i can't
control my body yeah no that was just a
crazy thing that i hope does not come
back and like so if you're sick even if
it's not covered stay the [ __ ] home
totally i completely agree that's sick
um okay so we'll talk about vanna pump
rolls in the tv recap segment but um how
was your day how was your tuesday it was
it was good you know it was another
bruise day we actually were really
bonded yesterday and
things were going well our heated
blanket finally arrived and even though
it wasn't exactly what i thought it was
going to be from qvc um it still has
been really special and i think brew is
enjoying it
so that's what matters most to me what
matters most to me is the fact that i
was alone last night watching the next
game because ben was like turn on i
think you could see me
and like of course i couldn't see him
but then
i guess it was like some big deal next
game yesterday we'll be talking about in
the stories you're lying some big sports
news wow was it a really bleak day for
stories yeah and i told you that
but i didn't realize it was that bleak
you looked you knew i did look yeah but
i figured you had all the bases covered
no and i love a little sports news and
this seems like a big deal and because
ben was there it's a bigger deal and you
know what let's not let's we not forget
the last time we spoke about sports news
we literally predicted who would win the
super bowl because it wasn't the san
francisco 49ers time it wasn't no it
really wasn't who was your pick again
for who's going to be in the super bowl
this year i don't [ __ ] remember some
reason i thought it was the bills versus
the books i did say something like that
everyone was like honestly that's a
really good call but i swear to god i
was watching tv on sun like zach was
watching a game on sunday and it was the
bills versus the box
so does that mean my thing's not
possible
maybe it was
maybe it wasn't that
i don't know you know what bill's first
buck sounds good yeah no the bills are
really having a great season
that's what i've been hearing from the
chatter from you know when i go to make
a snack yeah yeah yeah when i think of
the bills i think of um all those videos
of people throwing themselves onto
folding tables okay and then i also
think of o.j simpson
uh because he played for the bills yeah
like that's how i think i got famous i
always think about i just remember
seeing a video of like when the team
returned they like got really far and
like the whole like all the fans in
buffalo like went to the airfield and
we're standing outside the fences like
so excited to see them you know what
else i think about chase and tardik
because he's like obsessed with the
bills and then now i think of josh allen
who's the quarterback who i watch this
you know this promotional package about
and he just seems like a really great
guy oh god you know what i think about
when i think about josh allen i think i
relate to this man because he was like
the number one pick in the draft and
somebody exposed his tweets and he went
from being number one to being like
number a thousand really but he still
then he got like on the browns which is
like the worst team of all time because
like he was you know dropped but then he
picked himself back up you know got it
sounds like draft day honestly
especially if the browns drafted him and
you know what
what do they say about draft day you
never know what could happen you never
know what could happen on draft day and
that's
the sports segment from jackie and
claudius the first one of many yes
so let's just [ __ ] do it let's jump
right into the fast five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is sponsored by
betterhelp is there something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
well betterhelp will assess your needs
and match you with your own licensed
professional therapist in under 48 hours
better help is not a crisis line it's
not self-help it is professional therapy
done securely online there's a broad
range of expertise available which may
not be locally available to you in many
areas you can log into your account
anytime send a message to your therapist
and you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions so you won't
ever have to sit in an uncomfortable
waiting room as you do with traditional
therapy
better help is also more affordable than
traditional offline therapy and
financial aid is available because they
want you to start living a happier life
today join the over 2 million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
at betterhelp.com
toast that's betterhelp.com
toast to get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
toast special offer for the morning
toast listeners 10 off your first month
at betterhelp help
toast
wonderful our first story is some really
really cute sweet news about the campers
in the kardashian family the [ __ ]
kardashian campers are going to make me
cry mason disick advises kim kardashian
not to let northwest go live again so
last night um
kim posted to her stories a screenshot
of text messages from mason
that he's giving north some advice and i
think it's just like great
in general well if you didn't see before
this clip went viral
i guess north has an instagram now or
something she went she was sitting in
her house and she went live on instagram
for like a minute and obviously got
screen recorded and you know sent out
nationwide and she runs into kim's room
and it's just cool to see kim like you
know
after hours she's just laying in bed
scrolling her phone by herself and north
comes in she's like mom i'm live and
kim's like no you're not
she's like yeah yeah i mean him he's
like you know you're not supposed to do
that and then north the phone gets shut
down so it was just like a gorgeous
insight into you know i'm appreciative
to north for giving me that that moment
yes so then mason texted kim he
obviously heard about this and said hi i
don't want to disrespect north but i
don't think she should do the lives
unless someone is with her because
people are always screen recording and
she might tell information that isn't
correct and stuff like that that she
will regret i did the exact same thing
as she did i would do the lives and now
i regret saying one of the things that i
said just in case for safety
and then kim wrote i appreciate you
looking out mason and i agree she felt
bad and i don't think she will do it
again but it could be good if you talk
to her about it stop i'm gonna cry he
said i'd love to talk to her about it
next time i come over maybe then kim
said i would love that thank you
sleepover soon
so i okay uh we all remember the time
where mason was wildly letting us know
that travis and kylie are not together
and i actually think that that's the one
the thing that he regrets i mean i
didn't watch all of his lives i don't
know what he said what if no that was
the word but that was the big headline
and like no also there was the drama
with jeffree star
what did he say like he was going on
about jeffree star or something like oh
but did he say anything not factual no i
think he just started beef and jeffree
star was like
[Laughter]
anyways
it's just like that is the cutest text
message and i've never been
like such a like a amazing student
really kept up with him and i just
always think of him as like a mini scot
i feel like they have the exact same
personality they talk the same they
dress the same and then so to see a bit
of like his insightful personality
coming through i'm just like
is mason the number one camper in this
group right i mean the reason why i love
this story so much is because it's
layered first of all love to see a king
who you know
learns from his mistakes like you know
and not only is he learning from those
mistakes he's trying to spread the good
word to other campers so that the other
campers don't make the same mistakes
that he did right i thought the way he
texted kim was so respectful like i
don't want to disrespect north like
because north is obviously like
an intimidating [ __ ] like you know like
no one's queen of the bug right like
nobody [ __ ] with north like so i think
for mason to kind of step up like that
took balls it really did and he did it
in a really respectful way
i thought it was just the cutest
exchange of all time and i just like i
could literally dissect these text
messages for two hours i know and i know
people are like feeling weird that kim
posted them and i guess
she didn't need to post them but the way
that i read like i'm so glad that she
posts them because it really gave us a
window into you know the lives of these
campers and the dynamics between ants
and nephews and they clearly have like
really good heads on their shoulders the
only thing is like it's a little bit sad
that the kids can't just be kids you
know yes i mean
yes i thought the same thing like
the fact that like mason is leading a
life of regret because he went live and
said something untruthful which i'm sure
the kids at his in his school do all
that every single day
yeah so like the fact that they all have
these phones that could like literally
like
show us everything that goes on behind
the scenes and we're expecting children
to like understand those boundaries is a
little not normal for sure but that's
there's also a lot of benefits it's not
normal that they've never flown
commercial like of course no there's
pros and cons yeah for sure and i'm sure
even their parents like when they do
mess up with stuff like this like
probably aren't
don't make it as big of a deal as it
actually is because they're just trying
to punish them like normal kids like
stepped outside of the bounds as opposed
to like oh my god you just created
headlines around the world on north's
live like kim wasn't like screaming like
that was me i would literally like if
ben came in the room and i was like
sleeping and he was on live i would
literally slice his neck out like so kim
was better imagine if he was theo though
right um i would probably have a little
bit probably
yeah you don't do that kim was very
patient and the whole exchange
afterwards especially because it was
mason's birthday so i think she was
trying to show everyone like how mason
is so like mature and he really grew up
and she called him a respectful king
um an insightful king i think she just
wanted to show the world like this is
mason and you know what i really
appreciated that because i don't really
feel like i knew mason before this no i
agree or any like ideas that i had about
him or just not the mason that he
actually is like i feel like i know
north's personality i feel like i know
penelope too from her tik tok yeah but
to see this side of mason and he is the
oldest camper in the bunk and there are
so many campers these days and more are
coming and to know that he is like just
looking out for the bunk it's a
beautiful thing you know what i got from
this is that the bunk is in under
amazing counseling like
they are their fearless leader is not
too proud to own up to his mistakes to
learn from them to grow from them and to
share those lessons like
it's
i'm gonna cry you know and it's all it's
beautiful the lesson learned it's not
even
unique to just this bunk like these are
universal lessons yeah sharing social
media when you're young hello like yeah
just
what you got to watch out yeah
you got to watch your back and i'm just
really grateful that the kids they have
mason to look up to because he's clearly
like turning himself into some sort of
role model some like guru literally yeah
i agree this was a beautiful story i
think we could all learn from and
overall like i'm really glad that kim
posted these text messages even though i
know that other people are like why
would she post this and put mason on
blast now do you think that kim got
permission from courtney to post the
text messages me too i do i think that
would
that she should have gotten cursed and
you know what it goes without saying
because i think a lot of people are
really hard on courtney for some of her
like parenting decisions which is
no one's business
this is a testament to the way he was
raised and it's a testament to courtney
and you know if i was courtney i would
want these text messages shared too yeah
i agree
okay our next story someone else
speaking out ben affleck says he'd
probably still be drinking if he stayed
married to jennifer garner
that's nice
ben affleck is speaking candidly about
his relationship with alcohol during an
appearance on the howard stern show on
monday he got candid about his struggles
with drinking while married to jennifer
gardner with whom he shares three
children he said quote i'd probably
still be drinking it's part of why i
started drinking because i was trapped
i was like i can't leave because of my
kids but i'm not happy what do i do what
i did was drink a bottle of scotch and
fall asleep on the couch which turned
out not to be the solution
yeah i mean i guess this headline is
misleading he wasn't saying like
jennifer gardner trapped him like he
trapped himself in his own mind because
he wanted to stay with the kids yeah
they had but that's a harsh quote like
she drove me to drink and i'd still be
drinking and married to her was making
me drink yeah like justice for jennifer
garner i know but i feel like jennifer
garner like couldn't care less about ben
affleck yeah and when these stories like
i do feel like in their relationship
narrative it's like always like ben
affleck you know he was with the nanny
and stuff and he was always like the snl
writer and like even when they were
still married it was like he was the
villain and she's just like this sweet
innocent lady like being a mom and like
how can you do this to america's
sweetheart it's true and this just like
firmly asconces them in these roles and
so i don't think
this is doing any damage to like her
personal brand she's just like oh you
know like
yeah that's my crazy ex-husband yeah i
don't think she's bothered by it because
you're right and she's she's in a
relationship right she's like super
happy she's so moved on she's still
moved on like i don't even think she
literally could shed one tear for ben
affleck so
i honestly and you know i don't even
think she cares that he's back with the
woman that he was with before her like
that's normally something like a woman
would care about i think jennifer
gardner like so is so ambivalent about
ben affleck like it doesn't bother her i
agree with everything up until i think
that probably deep down she is very
bothered really yeah i don't think would
ever see a glimmer of it but i imagine
that's quite bothersome i don't know she
doesn't seem like the type of gal to be
bothered that's just how i perceive it
i i think
it's too big not to you know but it's so
much time like
but still it's like 20 years right the
history it's it's too it's not just like
an ex you know they were supposed to get
married like and then he totally flipped
the script and married jen and like had
all these kids and like that was the
happy ending and like then the plot
twisted again
i know but by the time like jen was
finally able to get rid of him like i
just i really don't know i don't think
she's like rdh and like oh my god what
about me but it's like
it almost like
i mean of course they have these kids
yeah just like wipe screen it's like oh
he was you know this feeling
the whole time like he was in love with
her all along i thought i was the winner
i don't know i see jen garner a little
differently than that but i i could see
your side of it as well yeah anyways i
don't i think that this you know just
kind of makes ben sound like
a dick um but he was also probably just
being honest like about how he got to
the place where he was at and drinking
and sometimes honest truth is ugly it's
hard yeah you know you know howard
brings that out in people yeah so and
i'm sure he's regretting saying it
because it's like no it's being picked
up everywhere yeah and it looks really
bad and it's a [ __ ] slow news day so
like this is literally the only thing
the morning choice is talking about yeah
no it was like number one story
everywhere um also probably one of my
favorite facts about jen and ben gardner
is that their daughter's name is
seraphina yeah because they have a
respect for a delicious restaurant for
the mcdonald's of italian cuisine yeah
so good i think i'll have that for lunch
today oh it's been a while for me it's
also kind of heavy for lunch but you
know what it's the wednesday before
winter break like [ __ ] it if you're not
having pasta for lunch what are you
doing [ __ ] it are you ready for our next
story only if it's next story that's
brought to you by the pill club life is
stressful enough access to health care
shouldn't be luckily getting birth
control is one less thing you have to
worry about with the pill club you'll
never have to make a trip to the doctor
or wait in line at the pharmacy ever
again because they provide access to
care from the comfort of your home and
delivery to your front door in discreet
packaging the pill club is a birth
control subscription prescribed by a
medical professional and delivered
straight to your door for free they
carry over 120 fda approved brands and
most brands of birth control are free
with insurance or medicaid otherwise
prices start as low as nine dollars per
month without insurance they deliver
birth control to your door for free and
discreet packaging and with the pill
club their licensed medical team is just
a text away to give you the best
reproductive health care
right now when you join the pill
club.com toast the pill club is offering
a 10 donation to bedsider.org for every
morning choice listener who becomes a
patient your donation will help
low-income individuals get access to
birth control through bedcider.org
that's
thepillclub.comtoast to get your first
birth control care package and donate to
help more women in need of affordable
birth control remember the pill club.com
toast you must use that link to make
sure the donation to bedsider.org goes
through thepillclub.com toast there's no
reason not to
great our next story the voice has
crowned a new winner spoiler alert the
winner of season 21 of the voice is the
band girl named tom which is a win for
team kelly which is really why
what i care most about i don't know what
like if most people care like which
judge which oh i care i feel like it's
such a big deal for the judges yeah and
the only like the finalists were from
team kelly team blake and team john yeah
ari was out first
which is really sad for ari which is
surprising too because i saw this cover
of ari and the two remaining acts on her
team um this woman who had the most
amazing voice and this father-son duo
and they did a cover of
four or five seconds by kanye palmer and
it and ariana did the cover too
they're sitting around this campfire
jackie you have to watch it it's one
it's the most premium content i've ever
seen they're harmonizing to perfection
and i was like oh the girl sitting on
ariana's right is obviously gonna win
the show but she didn't
damn i mean
there's a lot of talent over there at
the voice totally even though i just saw
a tweet that went viral that was like
you know i actually want to quote it a
hundred percent yeah give me a second
okay well you read the details girl
named tom's win marks a fourth victory
for coach kelly who also won last season
with her contestant jake hoot earlier in
the night she's won a lot because she
also won that girl britain four four
times yeah earlier in the night girl
named tom performed the jonas brothers
love before you leave me with kelly and
they beat out team fellow team kelly
contestant haley mia
and blake and john's finalists as well
okay i can't find the tweet but it was
basically just like
nobody from the voice who has one like
ever becomes famous it's basically just
a talent show one thousand percent but
there are a lot of people who are
extremely famous who like didn't win the
voice but were on the voice like morgan
wallin started out the voice ray lynn
it's really in country because like
blake shelton like does the work um but
people who have won i don't know one
person who's even remotely famous no i
totally agree it seems like a really fun
time it is a talent show and whether or
not you win has no bearing on whether or
not you will have success yeah but same
with like um american idol i would say
in the since the resurgence the most
famous person to come out of american
idol is gabby barrett and she did not
win
yeah
since the resurgence i haven't been
following since the resurgence oh i have
because it was
it was pretty good
um the gabby barrett season was actually
very good yeah but that was the first
season back yes and then since then they
did like covet seasons as we know from
ryan's bpr
where uh
was a digital producer yeah
um but back to the story so yes i'm very
interested in which i'm actually more
interested in which coach wins than
which artists can they really like use
it as bragging rights when they do their
banter all season long and so now like
kelly's sitting pretty this is two
seasons in a row and you know what with
ari like i hope this doesn't discourage
her and i really hope i don't know what
her contract was but i hope she stays on
i think first of all it's great for her
commercial appeal and i think she did
wonders for the voice like i've never
seen so much voice content being like
targeted towards me on social media
because she really just raised the bar
for everyone and i think it made her
friendship with kelly so cute and i
really
i really hope she comes back yeah i hope
so too i mean i'm sure the contract was
more than one season and it was a big
shuffle people in and out like nick
jonas was on the voice for 30 seconds
yeah but
they're just different you know
obviously and also someone sometimes
people come in as a judge and like you
just knowing your bones it's a temporary
situation yeah it's not permanent like
they're sitting in someone else's chair
i feel like they let you know that
you know yeah nick jonas definitely felt
temporary but ari does ari doesn't feel
like forever she's not like shelton but
i feel like she could be like a
gwen stefani who was there for a good
amount of time yeah
but she's just like she needs to stay
like for the show i'm telling you like
the show will not be be good without her
well once she's going back on tour and
stuff but i think
just this time in her life and she's
newly married so she's staying in l.a
local i think it's great for her she's
always like has looks and now her
instagram's like popping off because
she's dressed up every day she used to
just like take selfies and turn them
upside down and yes that and be the most
followed woman on instagram that's so
true but now it's really interesting
yeah you know i'm telling you like i
really hope that she's enjoyed it as
much as we have enjoyed watching her
walking welcoming her into our homes
agreed and i'm so happy for kelly like
we were just saying this yesterday like
it's all coming up kelly it's all coming
up kelly and this is further proof
happy for her and i haven't heard this
band but it sounds like um an alt a name
that was thrown out for tom sandoval and
his cover band but they decided to go
with tom sandoval in the most extras but
it could have been tom and the girls or
whatever the girl named tom yeah
are you ready for our next story which
is a little more tv contract news is it
the more tv contract news no it's not
okay no i don't think it is okay
it's that kathy hilton is reportedly
returning to real housewives of beverly
hills after getting more cash so rumors
have been swirling that kathy hilton was
asking for a big payday to return to the
real houses of beverly hills and now
they have made a deal so she will be
signing on as a friend of for the
upcoming season because that's what she
was last time yeah if even that she
wasn't like holding a diamond or
anything um
and she will be joining the girls even
though production has been halted
because of
a bunch of women got covered oh again
marcel not the same oh i saw garcelle on
twitter and rena
and one other person
interessant yeah very interessant
anyways she felt like she was being
undervalued on the show and now they
have reached a
she's right atreistis good do they say
how much she got paid now no
i'm curious it's definitely not above
like the highest paid ever was obviously
denise two seasons four million dollars
yeah but also it couldn't it can't be
more than what kyle's making because
that would just be like so upsetting and
if i were kyle like that i'm sure it's
already frustrating like cathy literally
comes on the season for the show for two
minutes like does nothing and is like
america's sweetheart whereas kyle's been
working at this for 10 years whatever
but i'm sure like it's fun to be able to
do it together but to come in in the
next season and make more than her i
think i don't think she would stand for
that also as someone who's not even a
full-time castmate right right but also
contracts are secret like they
kyle would only know if kathy's making
more than her if kathy's sharing what
she's making with kyle yeah no but if
kathy got like a blockbuster contract to
be a housewife like i do think that
might be in the news yeah and so i think
she would have to talk about it with
kyle beforehand oh my god that would be
so crazy if she ever does become a
full-time housewife she probably could
and would get paid more than kyle
because that denise got paid more than
kyle denise is a household famous person
kathy hilton of course but it's it's you
agree that it's different because
they're sisters like that would i don't
think that yeah but i don't think that
she should get paid less because her
sister's been on the show for two years
or like kyle should get paid if they
want to pay kathy like say it was
whatever two million dollars per season
and that's not what kyle's making then
they need to up what kyle's making i
just feel like that would be like so
yeah but that's you're a righteous
person but that's not how business works
no but even i remember like lisa rinna
said this once kind of
i don't know if it was on an episode or
a reunion or just off air where it's
like for the women who are making that
much more
you need to bring that much she said it
on radio andy i remember like about like
vanderpump like who was making the most
out of all of them and then like earn
your check yeah and the rest of us like
and i mean i don't think that
it should always be that literal but
there is some truth to it and so if
kathy's gonna be the highest paid
housewife then she needs to be working
the hardest
yeah but the thing about kathy is like
when she does the least it's what gives
us the most it's this weird dynamic i
know but i just think it would it would
cause
issues in the group if she really just
like floated her way in was making more
than all of them
it ain't right i hear you
but i see her the same way i see like
denise richards is an a-lister kathy
hill did on her own outside of the show
is an a-lister
that's what a-listers get paid right but
denise i think came in like ready to get
her hands dirty and like be a housewife
and that's exactly what she did and she
really you know what i'm through i'm
sure if kathy was a full-time cast mate
like she would make more of an effort
but she's just a friend of like she she
can phone it in
yeah but
i don't think that she like why should
she even really want to make more of an
effort do more than she's doing or like
get really in the weeds on the drama
she's not a dramatic she's she also has
the perfect setup she's literally i've
never seen a friend of sit for the whole
reunion right she's a unique better she
didn't sit the whole reunion did you
literally i actually think she did
they brought her out and then it was
squishy but she didn't leave
she was there like if she wasn't there
100 of the time she was there 95 percent
yeah
and that's never happened a scala was
there for a fl a flash
yeah
kim d kim ji
yeah one sec i have heartburn oh
do you want me to get you a tum or
something no i took my heartburn
medication like i actually think i have
a tongue in my purse though no it'll
kick in soon are you sure why not i have
a tongue no i have times too but like if
i already took medication i don't want
to take more tom is not medication it's
like a second candy a gross one are you
sure i'm sure thank you thank you for
your concern i
just love toms like i would never leave
my house without toms anyways i'm just
concerned about kyle because i just hope
you know that would be really
and i would understand kyle's
frustration kyle has put this show on
her back kyle built this show from the
ground up and i for the other women it's
like an honor to have kathy hilton what
is your sister it's like anyway
no it's it's just
it's different no and andy did ask at
the reunion like is there any jealousy
and she said no but the only and i
actually didn't i believed her but the
only time i thought there was like a
little bit of jealousy was when kathy
and kyle were on watch weapons live it
was just like the kathy show you know
yeah and it's just like it's so easy
like everybody loves kathy it's so easy
for her like yeah and she didn't have
the first seat and like she didn't even
care do you know i mean she was like
still the star in the second chair on
watch ravens live yeah yeah but like i'm
sure it's been that way like their whole
lives maybe you know where it's like one
people are just
different
to different people some people just
have to work harder
but you know what sister dynamics it is
and you know what
andy said it best i think
i think learning more about kathy really
made me understand kim
yeah i agree with that like and i
actually wouldn't mind seeing kim back
like the three gals back together even
though i don't think this show was good
for her sobriety i'm good
you are i like kids extremely good oh i
enjoy her i think she's like a pigeon no
like now i i do feel like i have a
better sense of her but i still don't
need her like on the show yeah so i
agree with half of what you said
are you ready for our fifth and final
story is it the fifth and final story
that's brought to you by manscaped
it's holiday season and you don't know
what to get as a gift or a stocking
stuffer well today's sponsor manscaped
has the tools to guarantee you win this
year's stocking stuffer competition
manscape thanks for giving us an excuse
to get all the gifts that our boyfriends
husbands partners have been needing
year-round they've changed more than
four million men worldwide for the
better um get 20 off and free shipping
at manscape.com when you use code toast
manscape's best-selling products is the
performance package 4.0 which is at the
top of every man's wish list this year
inside you'll find their lawnmower body
trimmer which is the best trimmer on the
market for his balls back chest the list
goes on and the weed whacker which is
the ear and nose hair trimmer they also
have their famous liquid formulations
like the crop preserver which is a ball
deodorant and the crop reviver which is
a ball toner to keep him smelling nice
down there you're getting a deal with
the performance package because if you
order now you receive two free gifts the
manscaped boxers and the shed travel bag
which is the best free gift ever um it's
just like a gorgeous leathery mature
thing like when ben used to pack you
just like throw his toothbrush in his
suitcase like now he has this nice
travel
pouch and it's just very mature
also all the manscaped products are
fabulous ben uses them all the ear
trimmer all the the serums they're just
a fabulous
manly like skincare
pubic
preserving company and it's a great gift
great stocking stuffer for your
boyfriend or husband and you can get 20
off and free shipping at manscape.com
with code toast cheers to rocking the
best gifts of all this season a gift for
him but really a gift for you
manscaped.com code toast i love a pubic
preserving company see i feel like i
should work in some sort of marketing
department like
that should i made that up that wasn't
even manscaped what if it's this
manscaped preserve your pubes
got it no i got a better one manscaped
preserving your pubes since
whenever they 2001. how is that better
i didn't say it right hold on
what did you say manscaped preserve your
pubes no mine was
manscaped preserving pubes since 2001. i
think that sounds better you think the
20 years of per preservation and i
didn't say your consideration i didn't
say europe i said preserving pubes right
because sometimes you do want to get a
gift for someone else and like if i'm
being marketed towards i really don't
want to think about my own pubes to be
honest you want to think about others
yeah okay cool good to know
so which story was this the fifth and
final
the final story
[Music]
and that's a magic number
[Music]
our fifth and final story a little
sports news steph curry makes history
breaking the nba's all-time three-point
record he's officially the greatest so
steph curry made history in front of a
madison square garden crowd which
included ben stauffer on tuesday night
by setting an nba record for the most
career three-point shots made the golden
state warriors scorer faced the knicks
needing just two three-point shots to
pass the former nba player ray allen's
career three-point record of 2973.
curry broke the record with seven
minutes and 34 seconds left in the game
who won the game
probably not the knicks honestly but
yeah i would assume who would even know
yeah
everyone's only talking about this and
also the former record holder was in the
crowd yes ray allen i saw that on tv i
was watching and i literally tuned in at
the perfect time ben was like put it on
i'm like i'm eating and then like i
moseyed my way over to my bed put it on
this second steph curry like took the
shot and everyone was freaking out i'm
like what is going on well i saw steph
curry take the shot because ben got it
on instagram ben got it on instagram and
ben is like floating on cloud9 because
like
the you know they're at every game
there's a million photographers a
million videographers but you know
always the best picture of like an
iconic moment like lasts forever in
history and the photo that like you know
the sports universe decided to use is
literally steph curry and ben like it's
actually the craziest picture it's being
posted everywhere and ben is wearing his
not like other girls merch with my face
on it which basically like i was there
too it's you steph in bed right and it
was just like kind of an iconic moment
for toasters
always and i love when there's a toasty
influence in an iconic moment me too and
i think ben was excited because he was
also wearing a spritz hat he's like a
walking billboard like yeah he's like oh
i'm going to the next game what should i
market today yeah no and i think he knew
he was going to have good seats and this
could be a history-making game and he
played it well this marketing man no it
was iconic like really truly iconic i
didn't hear much about the game
afterwards because ben was just like so
obsessed with this photo of himself he's
like everyone's texting me stop i'm
happy for him i'm happy
that's like for him that's like awesome
that's like being in the background of
kim kardashian's paparazzi picture yeah
i mean i wasn't margo was but yeah no
you were once remember after yes of
course of course just my leg but it was
good but then also margot was two once
yeah so no i understand that the power
of this moment for ben and i'm thrilled
for him i really really am um
yeah that's really all i can say and i'm
thrilled for steph obviously obviously
you love to see records being set you
know
greatness achieved and like the baton
passing you know from one generation
right allen is retired so like from one
generation to the other yeah and then
the guy on uh cbs or tnt who was you
know
emceeing the show the the game the
announcer the announcer yeah he held the
record before ray allen and he was like
when i had it there was no fanfare like
we didn't keep these records like you
know i didn't even know i
i broke the record
interesting yeah so it was like three
generations reggie miller is that who
that is sure i three generations of
record-breaking it was quite beautiful
wow that is beautiful
you know you love to see it it was a
star-studded game ben said he taught
pete davidson oh and pete davidson is
also in like all the iconic pictures
from last night because he's wearing a
neon pink hoodie and you just like can't
not notice him
who was he with um i didn't really uh
see anyone and i forgot to ask ben but
like ben's not he probably wasn't with
like obviously not him or anything i
feel like you know his sister or
something yeah well that's nice we would
have known if it was kim
obviously yeah
that's very cool i'm happy for ben i'm
happy for you know stuff steph the
golden state warriors the knicks that
you know something that they did people
cared about no that's huge for a new
york knicks fan i'm so glad you brought
that up and also what was really sweet
is that like the second he made the shot
he like you know got subbed out and like
ran to the crowd and hugged his mom it
was really sweet that's really cute yeah
gotta love an iconic sports moment you
know historic
yeah no it's cool to have big moments
who do you think is like the best
basketball player like of all time
that's a really controversial question
lebron lebron jordan
michael jordan no it's lebron versus
kobe no it's lebron versus michael
jordan i've seen um bad teachers so many
times they argue i feel like it's lebron
versus no jason siegel's always arguing
with the campers over lebron it's
though it seems as though none of us are
experts no but like what about kobe
kobe is a great player
but it's bomber story i'm gonna call
them okay
hopefully and then also get his take
on
like lebron or jordan everybody like who
has cares about these things has a
really strong opinion about it like ben
is obsessed with kobe maybe that's why
it's like in my brain yeah like no but
it's like i think also depends on the
position that you play because like even
though steph curry just beat this record
like it's not lebron versus steph that's
true so it's like how much of course
like this [ __ ] is always calling
me right he literally calls her during
the show every day all day every day
i could try my husband yeah why not i
don't have anywhere to be
no he didn't pick up pick up
i'm telling you i feel like i'm right
like i just know okay like i
wow straight to voicemail wow oh my god
are they cheating on us maybe they're
together being like oh and my phone's
broken oh my god okay do you know any
more men that you could call uh
it's actually
oh shapiro
no he's more football okay all right i
guess we'll never know no they'll let us
know it's lebron vs jordan and so who do
you think is the best player then
um like
i don't know i like don't know a lot but
just some of the information that i
gather is like i don't really get the
vibe that like lebron is like a team
player
um and i feel like that's an integral
part of being the greatest of all time
interesting what what makes you think
that i don't know i just like remember
when i used to like actually care like
about what ben was watching he was like
a ball hog when he was like in miami
heat you know yeah and also i think for
a lot of people i don't know if people
feel this way but just this is just like
how i remember it like when he left the
king charles cavaliers to go to the heat
just to like you know
dance down there and like live in south
beach and all that stuff it just
like he was not in it for the right
reasons
yeah and then he came back to cleveland
which was nice because that's his
hometown and he cares so much about
akron like he is the school but can you
imagine living in cleveland and leaving
no actually
no i couldn't i couldn't
so yeah i'm gonna go with jordan
i'm gonna go with jordan too because
he's a classic
yeah maybe it's easier for us to choose
jordan because he doesn't play anymore
it's hard to say that the person playing
right now is like the greatest to ever
do it you know but i
there are like a lot of stats that
people use to compare and contrast in
these arguments that happen every day
should we just take it to google
i don't know
you know i'm having phone problems so i
can't even do it like my my keyboard's
not popping up
they're trying to stop you from finding
out the truth that's true because it's
kobe
um okay well should we dive into the tv
recap yes which is brought to you by zoc
dock
has this ever happened to you you need
to see a doctor you search and find one
that looks good you wait on hold book an
appointment rearrange your schedule and
then when you finally go in you find out
the doctor doesn't even take your
insurance the worst but there's a
solution just download the free doc doc
app the easiest way to find a great
doctor and instantly book an appointment
with zocdoc you can search for local
doctors who take your insurance read
verified patient reviews and book an
appointment in person or on video chat
never wait on hold with a receptionist
again whether you need a primary care
physician dental dentist something more
specialized like a dermatologist
psychiatrist eye doctor sock doc has you
covered
go to zoc doc dot com slash toast and
and download the zockdoc app to sign up
for free every month millions of people
are using zocdoc and we're one of them
so make sure you go to zoc doc dot com
slash toast to download the app sign up
for free prioritize your health zoc doc
zocdoc.com
toast all right vanderpump rules was
like unbelievably infuriating because
i was feeling a lot of different
emotions like i just actually you know
has really really grown on me like 10x
raquel no
james no
ariana yes okay she's just like funny
and light and she really does not get
involved in this whole drama like and
you know she stands up for katie more
than her [ __ ] husband does so i
actually really like her aside from the
fact that she you know i have sympathy
for her she's like she has to live with
sandoval you know like i know
okay so when he was flat ironing his
yeah and she came to the bathroom and he
started singing a song about flat
ironing his hair and it was like really
painful um
what did you think about that i thought
that i wonder if like he's this annoying
on tv because
i have this whole thing in my head like
sandoval saw what stassi did and how
successful statsy was with her brand she
like created this like basic [ __ ] thing
and it was basic [ __ ] book basic [ __ ]
this basic [ __ ]
it was very seamlessly integrated over
the last seven years on the show and
that's why it was so successful
and i think he saw that realized he's
really not done
anything even remotely similar and wants
to replicate it and he's trying to jam
in what stasi did in seven years into
one season of vanderpump rules by being
actually by being extra in the bathroom
extra with his band extra in the
restaurant extra in the new restaurant
extra with his outfit extra with the
vagina candle extra with the basket he
brings extra at tom's house like he's
just trying to do the most so that like
he too can be successful outside of the
show now he has his cover band tom and
the most extras like it's so obvious to
me what he's doing so perhaps ariana
like sees him at work being extra and
he's like okay i can tune this out
because he's working right now i have to
imagine he's not that annoying no one
could live with someone that annoying 24
7. like i don't believe that yeah i
totally agree i also just have a
logistical question because it looks
like everyone was doing their own hair
and makeup for ariana's party which is
fine but then she said i need your help
with my hair i need your help with my
hair but her hair was like sickening
sickening best hair i've ever seen no
someone did it but why would she say
that i don't know someone did it why
would she say that i don't know somebody
did i was trying to figure out how
they could have done that together yeah
so i feel like what was interesting is
that this is the first episode where
ariana and stasi are not fighting for
like birthday things and like ariana was
like very um like light like she had a
really good time i was like happy for
her like happy to see her that way katie
maloney made me cackle so many times
during episode two she was being so
funny she is like literally my queen no
she was like her role on the show
this season is just to give a voice to
everything that we're feeling about tom
sandoval like i know a lot tom sandoval
has a lot of fans and people just like
love what he brings to the show and but
there are also people who like girls are
normal people they're in pain watching
this and she is there to represent us
and like then she said i would rather
lick tom schwartz's foot after a day at
disneyland in slides than have dinner
with tom sandoval that spoke to my soul
she's giving a voice to the voiceless
like she's just like literally a queen
like i just agree with everything she
says like off the bat it's just such a
delight to like have someone you can
really get behind yeah and i'm gonna and
i haven't felt this way about katie
every single season a lot of times like
i just went to each other i've disagreed
with her especially when you know if she
was like
going at it with her friends or whatever
but like this season just everything
she's saying is speaking to me and just
because she didn't give a [ __ ] her
attitude towards all of it is very
relatable i just the only thing i want
to push katie to do was like somebody
needs to give tom schwartz like an ass
whooping like if that was my husband and
he was out here like embarrassing me
not defending me taking up with someone
who's speaking to me in that derogatory
of a way like
the talking to that my husband would get
at home would you could feel the earth
shatter like i would
never accept that and i know she does
her best but i think she could go harder
on tom schwartz i don't think so i think
she i think i'm sure she's given him so
many talking to's and he sits there and
quakes and then when it comes time to
talk to tom sandoval he sits there and
quakes like he just like can't the
trucker's for tom trucker katie maloney
okay yeah
but like he really is quite infuriating
tom schwartz and i just felt like when
katie was crying outside of tomtom
because once again like you know tom
said that every all the money in her
house came from him which is insane and
also the way that he was talking about
branding them as a duo i did find to be
like creepy and
weird and also and predatory because you
know what like yes so so you're saying
like since the sidecar days you've been
trying to make you and tama brand and
you've always been doing it in a way
that like makes tom look stupid like you
make him like your side [ __ ] and you
know what everyone rihanna loves tom
everyone loves tom so i think tom
schwartz knows it like tom no sorry tom
sandoval knows that tom schwartz is like
an asset publicly and made it his
mission to like be a duo with him
without tom schwartz really knowing
because who the [ __ ] thinks like that
right and also like tom schwartz does
has a have a wife and if she's not down
for this and if she doesn't like you
then that's a problem and it was
actually so glad when lisa said that was
my idea because it was tom and tom were
never like they were always you know
really good friends but they also it was
tom tom and jack's like tom and tom
became like this duo brand at the
restaurant with the restaurant and that
was lisa's idea and when she said it
even i feel like a lot of the viewers
were like wait why would you give a sh
uh restaurant to thomas
like when there's what about like the
witches of weho or like tom never worked
at the restaurant there were so many
avenues she could have gone down and she
chose this one and that was really her
idea and like sandoval trying to take
credit for it and lisa calling him out
was a beautiful thing yeah no he just
took credit for that conversation with
some fury and i couldn't have sat there
and like let someone take credit for
everything
my my husband had done especially when
you when you really look at look at it
now like
from like a bird's eye view
he like kind of manipulated tom into
this partnership where like tom is never
thinking like oh how do i make my next
business move tom schwartz is never
thinking yeah and like tom sandoval
consciously like sought out this
partnership making tom schwartz like the
you know the dumb to his dumber like and
and then like wanting to be praised for
it when nobody asked you to do that
right also based on what i've seen this
season i think that tom sandoval is a
bit fiscally irresponsible when it comes
to his personal finances and also the
business like all of these loans that
are being taken out on a restaurant that
is a risky risky gamble like this isn't
the time to enter the restaurant
industry they already have a restaurant
now they're splitting up their time the
show's on its way
down things aren't it's not really a
good it feels like it's a last-ditch
effort for them to like make something
happen and it's far too late and i hope
like when we go to get to the reunion we
find out that this restaurant idea has
been put if either of them actually get
those loans like i will cry yeah it's
like whitney rose
but at least whitney rose has more
potential than a second restaurant from
tom tom i would say so yeah i would say
a beauty brand in kovid is very a good
idea and like she's on her way up this
show is on its way up like this is a
really bad idea on all counts and
i just anyways when katie was crying and
she was just like i'm just so tired i
just felt like she was like
maybe she did feel sleepy in the moment
but the way that i read it was like i'm
tired of this [ __ ] and like this show
and this dynamic and like [ __ ]
sandoval and like having to force you to
do what's right like for just i mean yes
but like i think like i think that's so
much of what katie ultimately loves
about tom is like his good naturedness
and it's a sword that cuts both ways
because he's not able to stand up to
people but i think she's just like tired
of having to play in the sandbox with
[ __ ] tom sandoval yeah no i think
you're 100 right i just don't really see
how this show can go on
and when i was listening to give them
lala
she was saying
that
there's like some i forgot her exact
words but like there's a chance that she
doesn't come back next season pretty
much she felt like completely on an
island at the reunion no one has texted
her since about like the
breakup and stuff except for raquel and
she was saying like that she might not
be back next season
that's crazy yeah i mean it's a sinking
ship like no one wants to be the last
one on it yeah and she has the like of
the og cast mates like she has the least
invested and tied it into the show
because we don't even see like give them
la la beauty stuff or any of her like
professional endeavors but like i mean
tom and tom are completely pulled into
the tied to lisa which ties katie and
ariana and i mean sheena as well
still works that sir yeah no does she no
not correct like they pretend to yeah
but she hasn't been fired yeah no but
sheena's always been like
kind of like a floater in the space yeah
and it works for her yeah um so it was
it was actually a pretty good episode
just because it like got me thinking
yeah it got me thinking too of course i
might you know there wasn't enough lala
which was frustrating yeah and it like
was making me sad like seeing like
randall helping her with her assistant
like knowing like we'll never see that
again she posted a tick tock like you
know every day for a week she's walking
out of her front door and like a
sickening new look and the caption was
like i didn't know what i was filming
this would be i'd be preparing for my
final exit like i guess she doesn't go
live in the house anymore like and she
doesn't plan on it
which sucks because that's such a nice
house yeah i wonder where she's living
right now i know
i like worry i know she was like the
whole time they were together she was
like very much understanding that like
it's a possibility that he'll do this
again i can't be financially dependent
on him so i'm glad that she did the book
she does a podcast she does la la beauty
like i i'm worried about her financially
like because randall was obviously you
know covering a lot of it yeah but she
has systems in place i think he and
she's a smart cookie yeah so
and her podcast was really good i was
really enjoying um
just like listening to it yeah girl talk
while i was getting ready it was a good
vibe um so the reunion should be good
also like with the raquel and james
stuff
yeah and then did you watch katie and
sheena and brock on watch what happens
live no how was it um it wasn't good
because it was virtual and so andy was
like out the door i'm surprised he's
been sitting in the chair not standing
by the door
[Music]
like couldn't give two shits what they
were saying ask them they would
literally give like an answer and then
like they would say one word and then
like launch into a sentence and he would
cut them off before the sentence like it
was quite painful that's the tough thing
like
the whole watch weapons live is so like
dependent on andy's mood and no human
being can be in a good mood all the time
and especially andy just is prone to i
think being in bad moods um it makes the
show extremely volatile and it's worse
when it's virtual because like he cuts
them off less in person because you know
when they're about to say something else
but like with the delay it's just like
yeah pretty painful yeah
so and i was just like i didn't
understand why brock was in frame too i
feel like he was supposed to bartend and
then for sure um
he is so thirsty like so thirsty and
then it didn't work out like him going
them going to new york and so he was
like but i still want to be on
that's really what i feel like happened
and so they actually had an audience
member bartending which was funny that's
cute it was just like a random guy from
ohio that was been like the best day of
his life
andy was like how is it over there and
he's like the same as over there
that's actually funny
um yeah brock is like so thirsty it's
actually uncomfortable like his intent
he doesn't even try and like be subtle
with his intentions like we know exactly
why he's with cheetah yeah no and him
saying like as saying you know i
actually post on instagram not give me a
kidney it's like
that's like just not what it's don't
like it's still a big deal it's it's a
big deal for these people yes
and
he doesn't get that because i guess he's
not a big deal for him yeah
um so that's the better bumpers recap
that's our show anything else you want
to talk about before we wrap it up
nope i think i feel wrapped up i just
started a new season of great british
bake off and so that's been delightful
quite soothing
i have like this roaring hunger pain in
my stomach like can we go have lunch
sure
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast milani morning show
where we deliver the fast five stories
that you need to know every monday
through friday on youtube so if you're
watching this on youtube please feel
free to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcasts can be found
so that's spotify itunes stitch oh my
ben's calling me back hold on hold on
you guys we're gonna get to the bottom
of it okay ben we're podcasting and i'm
gonna record you so don't say anything
crazy and i'm putting you on speaker
okay
[Music]
we were having a basketball debate you
know who do you think are the two best
basketball players of all time that
people are always doing who are people
always comparing
they're always comparing michael jordan
and lebron
okay i was wrong and what about kobe
no by the way
real ones know that the debate should be
between kobe and michael jordan oh i'm a
real one to not lebron
michael and kobe
michael and kobe what about lebron
michael there's a reason michael jordan
has a
12 billion dollar shoe empire yeah
jordan is the goat of goats
then there are two other people that you
can consider
when discussing greatest of all time and
you're either a kobe fan or you're a
lebron fan i personally have always been
a kobe fan and i will say real ones are
kobe fans
uh but you can't be both a lebron fan
and a kobe fan okay but then who do you
think is best michael lebron or kobe
michael
thank you have a great day i'll see you
at home love you wait jackie said that
lebron james was the greatest no no no
no we were arguing we have to listen to
you you'll have to listen to the episode
we were arguing over what the debate is
do people say it's claudia said people
argue between kobe and jordan no kobe
and lebron and i said no people argue
between michael jordan and lebron and
jackie was right
jackie was right thank you for settling
that i love you bye okay i'm so glad we
got that settled and you know what if
you made it to the end of this episode
drop a comment on our roast me most
recent instagram who's the greatest of
all time in basketball is it kobe is it
lebron is it
michael jordan or is it daniello
galinari or is it chris humphries
which i call ben back
thank you guys so much have an amazing
day and we'll see you tomorrow bye